في احدث حمله من حملات قمع ميليشيا الحوثي
لكل من يعارضها حكمت محكمه حوتيه بسجن
الناشطين على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
احمد علاوي ومصطفى مومري واحمد حجر وحمود
المصباحي الذين اعتقلتهم الميليشيا ومثلوا
امام المحاكم من يناير ووجهت لهم تهم
تقدير الامن العام والحاق الضرر بالمصلحه
العامه وتراوحت عقوبه السجن لكل منهم ما
بين سته اشهر لغايه ثلاث سنوات كما تم
تغريبهم عشره ملايين ريال ايما يعادل 4000
دولار وتم تداول انباء على ان محامي
الناشطين قد استانف الحكم الصادر بحقهم
وقال ان الحكم الصادر بحقهم وحكم جائر
وغير قانوني ومحاوله لتكميم الاصوات
المعارضه والمنتقده الاعلام الامني التابع
لميليشيا الحوثي كان نشر من ايام ما يمكن
ان نسميه مسرحيه لاعترافاتهم متابع
انا اعترف والكاميرا امامي واعترف ان به
فيديوهات طعمت الدوله في ظهرها صح
به فيديوهات استغل يعني فيديو
استغلها العدو صح يعني كيف اقول لك
احنا كنا نبث يا اخي السلبيه كنا اي شيء
سلبي نندع فيديو اي حاجه سلبيه
تواصل باحمد شاكر
وقال لي الجامعه مغلقه نشتي ما بالله توصل
لمصطفى لاجل ايش
يوصلها رائعه قال وصل صوتنا اهم شيء فيديو
ضخم قلت لها على طول يا احمد
طبعا الاتفاق يعني في البدايه قلنا له
عشره الف دولار تمام هذا قبل ما ادري اني
جامعه وانه رائعه
اهم شيء قلت لها عشره الف الفيديو هذا انا
اخطات فيه واسات على انصار الله في بعض
الناس مستائلين من انصار الله وانا ذكرت
انصار الله انا ما كنتش اشتي اعمم انا
اتهمتم غلط حكايه مثلا انهم بيخرجوا
فعاليات وبيخرجوا مسيرات ويفصلوا الموظفين
هذا هذا كلام كله فاضي هذا كلامك كله فاضي
كنت اقوم بمهاجمه انصار الله بالتغريدات
يعني كنت اهاجمهم
ومشفاهم دورهم للوطن ودفاعهم على الوطن
يعني ما كنتش فاهم اي شيء الدوري الذي
بيقوموا به كنت احسبهم ان الناس عنصريين
وان ما يحبون الا انفسهم وان لهم دعم
خارجي وكذا
للامانه يعني فانا محرج من كل تغريده
كتبتها
لماذا قلنا مسرحيه اعترافاتهم لانه ببساطه
هؤلاء الناشطون على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي هم ناشطون
صنعتهم الميليشيا وجنادتهم للدفاع عنها
ومهاجمه كل من يعاديها واليوم تحاكمهم
وتعاقبهم بعد انقلبوا عليها وهجموها ونشرت
الاعترافات التي شهدناها واللافت ايضا انه
رغم انه اتهمت مصطفى المومري واحمد حجر
وحموده المصباحي هي نفس التهمه وهي تقدير
الامن العام والاضرار والمصلحه العامه لان
الاحكام ضدهم جاءت بالسجن سنه ونصف
للمومري وسنه لاحمد حجر وسته اشهر لحمود
المصباحي اما احمد علاوي فتهمته الميليشيا
بنفس اتهم زملائه وزادت عليها تهمه اعانه
العدو وحكمت عليه بالسجن ثلاث سنوات
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا عبد الكريم المادي
القيادي في حزب المؤتمر الشعبي العام
اليمني اهلا بك استاذ بدايه ما تعليقك على
مسرحيه الاعترافات التي شهدناها قبل قليل
لتبرير الاحكام التي صدرت بحقهم
بالخير والمشاهد الكريم
شر البليه ما يضحك حقيقه
وما تقوم الان
للمواطن اليمني اولا واستغفر للحقوقي
واستغفر للاعلام واهانه اهانه للشعب
واهانه لكل انسان يراقب الوضع سواء كان
داخل اليمن او خارج اليمن نعلم جيدا على
ان
الاربعه كانوا اساسا هم ادوات مهمه جدا
ميليشيات الحوثيه وكانوا من الاصوات التي
تسوق للحوثي والتي تسوق الجرائم الحوثي
والتي يعني تحاول انها تبرر ما تقوم بهذه
الميليشيات وبالتالي انه يعني
ان تصل النتيجه الى هذا المرحله انا اتصور
بانه بالفعل هذه هذه هي نتيجه كل من يعمل
مع ميليشية الحوثيه وهذا جزاؤه كما جزيه
سينمار ان يتم القذف به الى الهاويه او
الى غياهب السجون الحوثيه يسمى بالضغاطات
نعلم نعلم جيدا على انه حصل لحقوق ايضا
المشايخ في صنعاء وفي عمران وفي حجه وفي
اب وفي اكثر من منطقه من من خدموا
ميليشيات الحوثيه وسهلوا دخولها الى درجه
انه تم اغتيال المشايخ في بيوتهم وفي
الطرقات من قبل
انتقاما منهم ولذلك الناشطون هؤلاء الذين
خدموا ميليشيات الحوثيه انا اعتقد انها
اضافه جديده من اضافات ميليشيات الحوثيه
الظلاميه وعبره لبقيه من يعمل مع ميليشية
الحوثيه تحت اي مسمى كان لكن برايك لماذا
انقلبوا على الحوثيين بعد ان يعني نفذوا
اجنده الحوثيين على مدى سنوات والان لماذا
انقلبوا ضد الحوثيين
لماذا برايك هو اولا هناك هما اكتسب هم
اكتسبوا شهره واسعه حقيقه الام يعني في
السوشيال ميديا وخاصه في يوتيوب وبقيه
المنصات الاخرى اكتسبوا شهره واسعه
واعتقدوا في لحظه معينه على انه ممكن
يضاعفه من يعني من منسوب هذه الشهره ويعمل
على انهم يدافعوا عن حقوق عامه ويدينوا
انتهاكات حوثيه وعلى ان الشهره ممكن ان
تحميهم من يدمي لشيئه الحوثيه لكنهم وقعوا
في فخ انه هذه جماعه ارهابيه وجماعه
ميليشياويه عنصريه وكان الاحرى بهم النوم
ممكن ينتقلوا الى منطقه امنه منطقه محرره
الى حتى لو استدعى الامر الى اي جبهه من
جبهات الجبهات الوطنيه المواجهه لميليشيات
الحوثيه وان يسخروا سمعتهم وشهرتهم وعدد
المتابعين لهم ومن ثم يكشفوا جرائم
ميليشيات الحوث
يعني انخدعوا بمساله على انه الشهره التي
حصلوا عليها قد تكون يعني حمايه لهم
وحصانه لهم في العاصمه صنعاء وهذا ما لم
يحدث عند ميليشيات الحوثيه التي عندما
تقرر ان تقتل فهي تقتل يعني الناس حتى لو
كانوا من ضمن قيادات هذه الميليشيات كما
حصل لعبد الكريم جربان واحمد شرف الدين
وعبد الكريم الخيواني وايضا
وزير الشباب والرياضه حسن زيد السابق لدى
ميليشيات الحوثيه انا اعتقد بانهم مليشيت
الحوثيه ايضا تريد ان توصل رساله وتقول
للمواطن اليمني والاعلامي والحقوقي
والسياسي انه حينما تتحدث ضد مسيره الظلام
والعنصريه والقتل سيكون مصيرك مصير هذا
وهذا وتجعل منهم عبره للبقيه لكن انا في
نقطه مهمه اعتقد انه الضريبه الدفاع عن
الوطن يجب ان تكون يعني جاهزه لكل مواطن
يمني ولا كل من يدافع عن ارضه امام عنصريه
طائفيه تحاول ان تبدد العقيده وتحاول ان
تجرف العقيده وحق المواطنه اليوم صنعاء
القديمه تحاول ان تجرفها مليشيات الحوثيه
وتدمر اربعه اسواق وتبني مكان هذه الاسواق
حوزه طائفيه شيعيه وكذلك الامر نفسه في
منطقه عصر لذلك
الاحكام التي انا الاحكام التي صدرت بحق
المومري واحمد حجر وعلاوي والمصباحي انا
اولا كمواطن يمني وكصحافي وكاعلامي
وادينها ادينها باشد العبارات واطالب
باطلاق سراحهم كمواطنين يمنيين في الدرجه
الاولى ومن حقهم انه يعبر عن رايهم عن ما
يدور من حولهم اريد ان اسالك وهذا اخر
سؤال لي بالنسبه لنهج الذي يستخدمه
الحوثيين لتكميم الافواه
لصنع جيش الكتروني يدافع عن اجنداتهم
ويروج لها في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وعندما ينقلبون ضدها يتخلون عنه ويهاجمونه
ويعتقدونهم اريد ان اعرف منك عن هذه
المنهج للحوثيين في الجيش الالكتروني الذي
تستخدمه
المنهج يا استاذه هو انه هذه الجماعه
اساسا جماعه منغلقه تماما وعنصريه تماما
وجماعه تستخدم العنف والارهاب باوسع ما في
الكلمه من معنى لديها طبعا اجهزه معينه
استخباراتيه واجهزه امنيه وهي اساسا يعني
سيطرت على مقدرات الدوله ومؤسسات الدوله
اضافه الى ذلك لديها خبراء من حزب الله
ومن الحرس الثوري الايراني هم من يضعون
المخططات وهناك ايضا ممن تعلموا من
ميليشيات الحوثيه وتدربوا على ايدي الحرس
الثوري الايراني ورجعوا الى اليمن لكي
يعملوا ضمن هذه الخطه وعملوا جيش الكتروني
واسع جدا حتى انه في الفتره الاخيره عملوا
على انهم ينتقلوا الى منصه تويتر وهي منصه
مهمه جدا وكانت تكشف كثير من جرائمهم من
خلال حسابات يمنيين وحسابات عرب حاولوا
الان ابن جيشه جيشا الكترونيا في هذه نعم
نعم وضحت الفكره شكرا لمداخلتك عكانا معنا
عبد الكريم المادي القيادي في حزب المؤتمر
الشعبي العام اليمني